I've been talking about the ideological
commitment of some may be many trumpets
and there's a new poll that stunningly
confirms this
even though Donald Trump jr. has
admitted to meeting with the Russian
lawyer Natalya vessel mitts kaya in
Trump Tower only 45% of Trump voters
actually believe that that meeting took
place Trump jr. admitted that the
meeting took place he admitted that he
was told he was going to get damaging
dirt about Hillary Clinton there's no
denying that it took place whatsoever
and most trumpets still don't believe
that it took place according to the same
PPP poll 32% of Trump voters say the
meeting never happened and 24% aren't
sure a minority of Trump voters believe
that the meeting that Donald Trump jr.
admitted to actually took place
remember that trumps own emails provide
written evidence that Russia wanted to
help Donald Trump win the election yet
somehow only 26% of Trump voters are
willing to admit that and this might be
the most bizarre result from this poll
44% of Trump voters believe that Russia
wanted Hillary Clinton to win the
election something that is completely
outrageous in its total lack of evidence
even if it was discovered that Trump did
collude with Russia definitively in some
kind of legal you know investigated way
only 16% of Trump voters believe that
Trump should resign as a result of that
and that's why you know there's this
cult of personality the entire I could
shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and people
would still support me thing we might
actually see Trump get away with
whatever it is that took place because
there does not seem to be much of a
desire from Trump ists to actually hold
him accountable for any of this stuff
the only people that I expect less of
than Donald Trump are Trump supporters
and
poll that comes out about this is
supporting that it didn't matter to them
that Donald Trump said hey I grab them
by the [ __ ] when I want it didn't
matter to them that Donald Trump is a
sexual predator or made fun of a
disabled reporter or that he lies
constantly so I guess it shouldn't be
shocking to us that very few trumpets
are saying even if Russian collusion is
proven Donald Trump still shouldn't
resign and this is why I am skeptical
about the actions that will be taken by
Republicans I don't know what we're
going to find out beyond any reasonable
doubt as a result of the multiple
investigations into Trump collusion with
Russia money-laundering obstruction of
justice the cover-up whatever why would
Republicans actually take action if
there's no desire even from the most
committed trumpets for any repercussions
if Donald Trump has done the worst of
what he's accused of having done
why would you act in that way and this
is why although if Trump's approval
rating stays low or drops even more that
might be a reason that Republicans would
start to bail on Trump but at the same
time if polls are telling us that Trump
is don't even care if the guy colluded
with Russia and they don't even believe
the stuff that Trump jr. has admitted to
doing why would they go out on a limb if
it comes to that point and say yeah
let's let's let's move to impeach the
president it's not looking good and and
by the way in the background this is why
Democrats need a platform now for 2018
and we might when we take calls maybe
we'll get some calls about this
Democrats need a platform and waiting
around for Trump Russia to implode
whether it will or won't implode it's
not a good idea and Democrats need a
strategy they need a platform I've been
talking about it and you can talk about
it with me on Twitter I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman follow me there send me your
thoughts about this the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com
slash membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted seventeen for a 40% discount off
of your membership